Do you remember the boxes?
>> What boxes?
>> These boxes.
>> Huh!
>> You do remember them?
>> Oh yeah, yeah.
I do remember them.
They're variables,
where you can put the value inside.
Yeah, and
you can combine multiple of these
variable to create a larger Java object.
>> Oh, so you can take two or
more variable and
make into a something bigger.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay
>> [SOUND] Like a TextView.
>> Yeah.
So, we can have an integer variable.
>> This is for the font size.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
[SOUND]
>> And then you can also have
a string variable.
>> And the string variable for
the actual text itself.
>> Yeah, and those can go inside the
TextView as the state of the TextView.
>> And then we can interact with those
things using different methods that
we're going to play with next.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
Let's do that.
>> As we mentioned earlier, showing
a TextView on the screen like this
is actually controlled by
a Java object within the app.
This is an example of
a TextView Java object.
It's like a box, and
inside of it, it holds state.
The state is made up
of a bunch of fields.
A field is a variable,
like in lesson two,
when we learned about global variables.
We can have a text field
to store the today string,
which is going to be the text that's
ultimately displayed on the screen.
We can also have an integer field to
store the font size of this text.
There's also a bunch of other fields,
like text color, font family that
make up the state of the TextView.
I just didn't draw them in this picture.
To interact with this Java object and
change it while the app is running,
we can call methods on the TextView.
We learned about methods
earlier in lesson three.
Some example methods on a TextView
are setText and getText.
You can also have methods like
setTextSize or getTextSize, and so on.
Each of these methods just
executes a list of instructions.
You can have more complex
methods like onDraw,
which handles drawing
a TextView onto the screen.
So overall, this TextView object holds
state information on what this TextView
contains, and you can call methods
to interact with this TextView,
such as to modify the state,
or to do more complex actions.
To show an ImageView on the screen,
we actually have a Java object for
ImageView inside of the app.
This particular ImageView contains state
information, like which image should
be shown, as well as the scale type,
like center crop.
Again there's a bunch of other fields
that make up the state of an ImageView,
I just didn't draw them here.
There's methods like setImage,
setScaleType, and even more complex
methods, like onDraw, to handle drawing
this ImageView onto the screen.
Note that, as developers,
we don't explicitly have to call onDraw
to tell it to draw onto the screen.
Android handles calling this
automatically for us, but it is useful
to be able to call these methods to
change the ImageView, for example.
So how do we know what all the fields
are inside the state of an ImageView,
and what all the methods
are of this ImageView?
To answer that question we have to look
at the class definition for that object.
It's a file called TextView.java,
similar to how we defined
MainActivity.java.
Inside this class TextView file,
we have a bunch of code that
talks about the state of
the TextView as well as the methods.
Now it doesn't say state and
methods exactly, but it just contains
information on the state and
it contains information on the methods.
You can thank of this as defining
the rules of how a TextView behaves.
This object instance can hold specific
information like the text string today.
Or the text size 18.
You can also use this class to create
even more TextView object instances,
and these could have
a different text string value.
I think this one could
hold text that says hello,
and this one could hold
text that says goodbye.
They could have different font sizes,
different text colors, etc.
However, they're all based
off of the class template.
You may find it hard to distinguish
between a class and an object instance,
but that's okay.
It takes some time to get used to.
Here's an analogy to help you.
You can think of it as creating
a floor plan for a house.
You can use this floor plan
to create the actual homes.
Each of these homes can
be slightly different.
But they're all based off
of this base floor plan.
It's important to note that the floor
plan is not a house itself.
It's just the plan.
Similarly, the TextView class is used
to create these object instances.
So these instances are the ones
with the actual text values,
text color values, and text sizes.
So what does one of
these classes look like?